what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and of
course spider-man no way home we've all
been waiting for this second trailer and
now we know when it's coming however
there is a catch to this and it will be
exciting for some and not so exciting
for some others but we do have that
official date and you're gonna want to
pay attention to what i'm about to say
and of course subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest spider-man
news because there should be more coming
very very soon possibly today and of
course we're giving away a spider-man
action figure if you'd like a chance to
win subscribe to my channel and the
channel cosmic culture and leave some
comments on the most recent videos okay
so check this out the official release
date for the second and official
full-length spider-man no way home
trailer release date has been revealed
but it's only going to be shown at a fan
event in la sony pictures in marvel
studios have officially announced an
exclusive live fan of it in la on
tuesday this upcoming tuesday november
16th where a select group of people
slash winners which i'll talk about in
just a second will be able to see the
official spider-man no way home
full-length trailer the second trailer
we've been waiting for on the big screen
here's the official announcement from
sony trailer launch fan event with big
surprises tuesday november 16th at 5 00
pm l.a time pacific time doors open at 4
pm seated by 4 45 pm it will be at the
regal sherman oaks venue seating is not
guaranteed and is on a first come first
serve basis this invitation is strictly
non-transferable full names will be
checked at the door now the catch is
it's unconfirmed at this time if they're
also going to release it online as they
show it at the fan event but seeing as
how it's a big specific fan event to
show specifically the trailer i would
not be surprised if they did not show it
online at the same time and kept it
pretty exclusive to these people going
to see it that's a bummer but the good
news is they probably will show it
online sometime soon after maybe not
that same day maybe the next day maybe
the same week who knows but it should
come soon but if you would like a chance
to try and win tickets to it there are a
couple of ways you can do this if you
live in la or have the ability to fly to
la on tuesday or before you can email
phase0 comicbook.com with the subject
spider-man la they only have 40 tickets
to give away or you can email collider
at thecollidermailbox
gmail.com they have some tickets to give
away as well and put in the subject line
i love spiderman and as of right now
that's all we really know about how to
be able to go to this event so it's
going to be pretty special because not a
lot of people are going to be there and
they're going to show the trailer and it
looks like maybe perhaps some celebs
might show up who knows about that one
but they do say surprises so if i hear
anything about the trailer dropping
online at the same time or shortly after
i will be sure to let you know so
subscribe hit that notification bell so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
videos hit the like button and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof